and which made me remind reminded me of
our conversation that we had through
email about Roseanne Barr oh yeah yeah
right oh yes of course
yes and about ambien yeah and about the
effects of ambien she came on the show
she still hasn't um she can't she's
having a really hard time with this she
feels terrible about what she said she
feels like the whole world hates her she
feels like she's lost everything and her
life is destroyed and she's distraught
and she she was going to fly out here
but we had a conversation and we kind of
decided to be probably better if she
waited just let let some of this pass by
it's still in the news because they've
decided to move the show on without her
there they're gonna kill her off or
something yeah and she's just devastated
and you know she was also devastated
health-wise physically she's an older
woman and not that it been any different
she was an older man just an older
person and this grueling schedule of
doing a television show was horrible on
her it just it was really really tough
to do she got bronchitis she felt like
she was almost dying she was completely
exhausted and she felt like the schedule
of it all just was just way too taxing
on her physically then on top of that
she's on a host of different things
she's I mean she'll if we ever do wind
up sitting down and talking on the
podcast I'll get her to list the various
things she's on but she's on various
antidepressants that she changes him up
mixes him up she was one of the things
she said to me she's she needs to get
her doses readjusted she drinks alcohol
regularly she smokes marijuana regularly
she's also on ambien regularly takes it
every night to go to sleep and I tried
to explain to her the fact that you're
not getting real sleep when you're on
that this is not something you should
take and rely on on a daily basis they
even tell you to get off of it I mean
it's it's and it's difficult to get off
of it but
people want to dismiss the idea that she
could have said something that's
completely out of character or done
something that's completely out of
character while under the influence of
this stuff that it could have
contributed to that they want to dismiss
it because they want a villain they want
you know no she's bad they want this
like this childlike
simplistic reasoning and rationalization
for what she's done
right and this is you know a prime
example of this sort of schizophrenic
nature of the way drugs are depicted in
our society if it's if it's something
like bath salts or k2 they're
responsible for everything one toke of
that stuff and you're eating your best
friend's face under a bridge
but then in Roseanne's case they have no
explanation whatsoever no exclamatory
value they can't be used to explain
anything
is it an excuse no is it an explanation
I think yes I think that the
intoxication can explain all sorts of
inappropriate behavior and to pretend
otherwise is again dishonest I know and
Sanofi the pharmaceutical company that
manufactures ambien had this widely
shared tweet saying that racism isn't a
side effect of ambien but it's a little
bit ridiculous for them to have done
that you know especially to someone
who's mentally ill because you know if
you look at the medical literature the
fact of the matter is that ambien is
associated with all sorts of absurd
behaviors command hallucinations where
people stab themselves jump out windows
people that you know butter their
cigarettes and smoke them people that
paint their houses in the middle of the
night with no memory whatsoever and it's
a profoundly profoundly disinhibited
drug so you know here's maybe a somewhat
analogous example from my own life I
never take ambien on planes for this
reason because I'm around strangers I
don't know what I'm gonna say or what
I'm gonna do let alone use Twitter but I
don't it's uncomfortable because it's so
disinhibited I might do something weird
I don't know take off my shirt I have no
idea you who's to predict what you're
gonna do when you have no inhibitions
whatsoever so I remember once I was on
the plane to Berlin and I
take ambien and I start in the sort of
delusional state thinking that the cabin
crew and the person that's announcing
over the intercom is saying various Nazi
things that's like an unfair stereotype
that all Germans are Nazis that's
offensive but I had no control over this
like just because they're German talking
in German doesn't mean that this is like
a Nazi airship because you're just
completely out of your mind
Wow but again I mean I like another
story I used to be friends with a girl
whose dad was a psychiatrist prescribed
her immense quantities of ambien and she
would snort it there's no reason to
snort its water soluble has a fast onset
of action there's no benefit and
snorting it it's fine orally if you're
gonna take it at all and there's no
reason to take high doses it's already a
deliriant at the therapeutic dose you
don't need to take more even five
milligrams induces delirium but but I
remember that I was at some party and
someone was saying that they wanted
ketamine and didn't at the party of
ketamine and she's a complete stranger
and I said oh I actually have a little
bit of ketamine but it's at my apartment
here are the keys and here's my address
and just run over to my apartment and
greet it and help yourself talk to you
later
and and then I'm one of these people
I've never lost my phone never lost my
keys I don't lose things so then I you
know wake up the next morning go to my
apartment reach into my pocket my keys
are gone and then it hits me this flash
of oh my god I gave my keys away to a
complete stranger to go to my apartment
and take ketamine from me what on earth
was I thinking what like what level of
disinhibition is required to do
something that insane luckily I was
there had to spend the rest of the day
tracing finding out who that person was
getting my keys and these people happen
to be very courteous people and actually
did go to my apartment did take the
small amount of ketamine that I had and
then just lock the door after themselves
and didn't make a mess but again I mean
this is it like this is a profoundly
disinhibited substance and also I think
the idea that a drug couldn't modulate
racist activity is interesting as well
because there's a study that you can
look up
where they used the beta-blocker
propranolol and they found that it
actually seems to block racial implicit
racial bias in people in certain tests
that what they're suggesting is that
there's an ad reject component to
implicit racial bias but there's a
certain maybe heart rate or fear
response and once that that's
physiologically blocked you become less
racist in a sentence implicitly it's not
a conscious decision conscious racism is
introduced but an implicit racial bias
is I mean these are like really
complicated higher-level questions about
how drugs impact cognitive functioning
and and the bottom line I think is be
careful as being certain about anything
about what drugs can or can't do what
does this Jim oh this is this story
blood pressure drug reduces inbuilt what
is that word in built racism common
heart disease drug may have an unusual
side effect of combating racism wasn't
that a [ __ ] that was that stupid
movie with Jack Nicholson and Helen Hunt
as good as it gets
he was a racist and they gave him a pill
they gave him some medication and
reduced racism